so much so that I, you know, we weren't paying attention to the time and I missed my flight back down to Southern California. I'm actually still angry about the whole thing. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode, recorded on May 19th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we continue our conversation with Sean Parent and get into some epic stories about Sean Parent's time at MacHack and how he got hired at Apple. So yeah, I've heard, I'm not sure if I've heard about every single one of these stories, but I've definitely heard of a couple of them.
以至于我，你知道，我们没注意时间，我错过了回南加州的航班。其实我现在对整件事还在生气。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客节目，录制于 2021 年 5 月 19 日。我是康纳，今天与我的联合主持人布莱斯一起，我们继续与肖恩·帕伦特的对话，并深入探讨关于肖恩·帕伦特在 MacHack 的时光以及他是如何被苹果公司录用的史诗般的故事。所以，是的，我听说过，我不确定我是不是听过所有这些故事，但我绝对听说过其中几个。
So Sean, if you can take us back to, I think it's 1988, 1989, and tell us your Mac hack stories, because these are awesome. But first, Connor, how old were we in 1989? That's not nice. We both weren't born. Yeah, I think my youngest son is older than both of you guys. So that says something. Yeah, so a little background, I guess, here.
所以肖恩，如果你能带我们回到，我想是 1988 年、1989 年，给我们讲讲你的 Mac Hack 故事，因为这些故事太棒了。但首先，康纳，1989 年我们多大？这可不太友好。我们俩都还没出生。是的，我想我的小儿子比你们俩都大。所以这就说明了一些问题。是的，所以我想这里需要一点背景介绍。
In that time frame, I had graduated from Seattle University and was trying to get established with a career. I landed a job at a little company called Orange Micro. They were a hardware manufacturer down in Anaheim. They were known for something called the Grappler, which was a parallel card to plug in printers into an Apple II. And they were pivoting and doing these smart cables for Macs. So it was a serial cable you could plug into a Mac and in the cable it did serial to parallel conversion and escape sequence conversion and would let you print to Epson printers, you know, or non-Apple printers, which sounds silly these days,
在那个时间段，我从西雅图大学毕业，正试图在职业生涯中立足。我在一家名为 Orange Micro 的小公司找到了一份工作。他们是阿纳海姆的一家硬件制造商。他们以一种叫做 Grappler 的产品而闻名，那是一张用于将打印机插到 Apple II 上的并行卡。他们当时正在转型，为 Mac 制作这种智能电缆。所以它是一根你可以插到 Mac 上的串口线，线缆内部进行了串行到并行的转换以及转义序列的转换，并且可以让你打印到爱普生打印机，你知道的，或者非苹果打印机，这在今天听起来很傻，
but that was a problem at the time. And so I spent some time doing firmware on this, and then kind of pivoted and said, okay, well, I could do a print spooler, and this was before the Mac had multitasking, and so I basically had to figure out how to write a multitasking system for the Mac so I could render graphics and print in the background and then the once I kind of had that going it was like oh well now I can take over a lot
但这在当时是个问题。所以我花了一些时间在上面做固件，然后差不多转折了一下，心想，好吧，我可以做一个打印后台处理程序（print spooler），这在 Mac 拥有多任务处理功能之前，所以我基本上得弄清楚如何为 Mac 编写一个多任务处理系统，这样我就能在后台渲染图形和打印，然后一旦我把那个弄好了，就觉得，哦，好吧，现在我可以接管很大一部分
of what was on the done in the little firmware and we could handle more complicated cases so so we had like the first solution to plug a Mac into an HP laser jet or an HP deskjet printer to use one of those laser printers instead of Apple's laser printer, which was ridiculously expensive at the time because it had a more powerful computer than the computer you were using in order to run PostScript to render graphics. And so that's what I was doing. And then, you know, I asked my boss, I said, hey, there's this conference called the Macintosh Technical Conference in Michigan. And could I go? And so he was like, sure, you could go.
以前在小固件中完成的工作，我们就可以处理更复杂的情况了，所以我们有了类似的第一套解决方案，可以将 Mac 插入 HP 激光打印机（HP LaserJet）或 HP 喷墨打印机（HP DeskJet），使用那些激光打印机而不是苹果的激光打印机，苹果的激光打印机在当时贵得离谱，因为它拥有一台比你正在使用的计算机更强大的计算机，以便运行 PostScript 来渲染图形。这就是我当时在做的事情。然后，你知道的，我问我的老板，我说，嘿，密歇根州有一个叫做麦金托什技术会议（Macintosh Technical Conference）的会议。我能去吗？所以他觉得，当然，你可以去。
So the alternate name for the Macintosh Technical Conference was MACAC. And this was in Ann Arbor, Michigan. And was this run by Apple? No, no, it was independent. It was run by the Mac Hack Group. And the people who ran the Hack Contest, which is what it was known for, were Scott Boyd and Greg Marriott. So they ran the Hack Contest, and the one rule at the hack contest was that Scott and Greg make the rules. But the hack contest kind of dominated the conference. And so the conference was a technical conference, and people presented papers and gave talks, and there were a couple of tracks. It was a relatively small conference, a couple hundred people.
所以麦金托什技术会议的别名是 MACACK。这在密歇根州安娜堡。这是由苹果公司举办的吗？不，不，它是独立的。它是由 Mac Hack 集团举办的。运营黑客松比赛（Hack Contest，这也是它闻名的原因）的人是斯科特·博伊德（Scott Boyd）和格雷格·马里奥特（Greg Marriott）。所以他们运营了黑客松比赛，黑客松比赛的唯一规则就是斯科特和格雷格制定规则。但黑客松比赛在某种程度上主导了整个会议。所以这个会议是一个技术会议，人们发表论文并进行演讲，有几个分会场。这是一个相对较小的会议，有几百人。
And they would invite in a keynote speaker. They had some really amazing keynotes over the years. The keynote always started at midnight on the first day of the conference. And the conference ran three days, so it was 72 hours. And the keynote speaker would start at midnight and could talk as long as they wanted to talk. And I think the record holder was Ted Nelson. I don't know if you guys know who Ted Nelson is. I did not.
他们会邀请一位主题演讲嘉宾。多年来他们有一些非常精彩的主题演讲。主题演讲总是在会议第一天的午夜开始。会议持续三天，所以是 72 小时。主题演讲嘉宾将在午夜开始演讲，并且想讲多久就讲多久。我想记录保持者是特德·尼尔森（Ted Nelson）。我不知道你们是否知道特德·尼尔森是谁。我不知道。
Ted Nelson invented the concept of hypertext kind of pre, before there was a web, and worked on a project called Xanadu, which is where a lot of the ideas for the modern web came from. But Xanadu was kind of this nutty system where you had links were bi-directional. So if you created a link to something then you it wasn't just to the thing but the thing created a link to something, then you... it wasn't just to the thing, but the thing that you linked to could also get back. So it was like, you know, built-in Google search into the links. And this was... I don't know, this was maybe 88, 89. Ted Nelson gave this talk on Xanadu, and this was way before the web existed, and talked for probably six hours, you know, so from midnight to 6 a.m. And I thought the man was brilliant, but completely nuts.
特德·尼尔森在网络出现之前就发明了超文本（hypertext）的概念，并参与了一个名为 Xanadu 的项目，现代网络的许多灵感都来源于此。但 Xanadu 是一种有些古怪的系统，其中的链接是双向的。因此，如果你创建了指向某物的链接，那么它不仅指向该物，而且该物也会创建指向某物的链接，然后你……不仅指向该物，而且你链接到的东西也可以返回。所以它就像是，你知道的，将谷歌搜索内置到链接中。这大概是……我不知道，这大概是 88、89 年。特德·尼尔森发表了关于 Xanadu 的演讲，这远在万维网存在之前，并且讲了大概六小时，你知道的，从午夜到凌晨 6 点。我觉得这个人太天才了，但也完全是个疯子。
You know, he put up all these slides going, you know, we're going to build this. It's going to be this, you know, worldwide system. You'll be able to link to anything, anywhere. One key feature of Xanadu was there was no deletes. So you had like full history of everything. And everything was distributed, you know, in the cloud. You literally would use the term the cloud. And you could get, and you know, you would put up all these graphs about there was no reason why we would ever need to delete anything because the the cost of storage was falling so rapidly and on such this such the sharp decline that you know all the textual information that had ever been produced by mankind could be stored and replicated within
你知道，他展示了所有这些幻灯片，然后说，你知道的，我们要构建这个。这将是一个，你知道的，全球范围的系统。你将能够链接到任何地方的任何东西。Xanadu 的一个关键特性是没有删除功能。所以你拥有所有东西的完整历史记录。而且一切都是分布式的，你知道的，在云端。你简直会直接使用“云”这个词。你可以获得，你知道的，你会展示所有这些图表，说明为什么我们永远不需要删除任何东西，因为存储成本下降得如此之快，而且处于如此急剧的下降趋势中，以至于你知道人类曾经产生的所有文本信息都可以被存储并在其中复制
this cloud without breaking a sweat, especially since, you know, if you copied and pasted, those were just links and you weren't actually copying anything. And so it tended to be a pretty dense format. And what he didn't anticipate was video and the amount of storage space that, you know, video and audio circulating on the web would take. But otherwise, he was pretty spot on. But yeah, so in any case, I went to my first Mac hack in Ann Arbor, and this would have been 88. Yeah, it would have been 88. So that was the first one that you saw Ted Nelson speaking? I don't know if he was at that one or he was the next year.
这个云端毫不费力，尤其是考虑到，你知道的，如果你复制和粘贴，那些只是链接，你实际上并没有复制任何东西。因此它往往是一种相当紧凑的格式。而他没有预料到的是视频，以及在网络上流通的视频和音频将占用的存储空间大小。但除此之外，他的预测相当准。但无论如何，我去了我在安娜堡的第一次 Mac hack，这应该是在 88 年。是的，应该是在 88 年。所以那是你看到特德·尼尔森演讲的第一次会议吗？我不知道他是那一次还是第二年。
I think he was probably the next year. And how many years had MACAC been going? This had been on your radar for a while or you found out about it rather recently? There had been maybe one or two before that. I could probably look it up, the history of MACAC. It was not the first MACAC conference. So I went, and, you know, relatively young guy, and didn't know anybody, was working at this, you know, small company, Orange Micro. When I'd hired in, they'd just gone through a restructuring,
我想他可能是在第二年。MACAC 已经举办了多少年了？这个会议在你的雷达里出现很久了，还是你最近才发现的？在此之前可能有一两届。我可以查一下，关于 MACAC 的历史。这并不是第一届 MACAC 会议。所以我去了，你知道的，作为一个相对年轻的家伙，谁都不认识，在这家，你知道的，小公司 Orange Micro 工作。我刚受雇时，他们刚刚经历了一次重组，
and I was the only software person at the company. And so I went to the conference and decided, well, I'm going to do a hack. And the idea with a hack was you should come up with the idea for the hack while you were at the conference. Don't bring code. Code it while you were at the conference. Hacks should be collaborative. They didn't have to be. But, you know, get a group of people together to work on your hack. And it could be anything that demoed well, right? So I had an idea for a hack to do a floating clock on the Mac. And this was before Mac had Multifinder. So Mac was, like I said, it was one app at a time, no threads,
我是公司里唯一的软件人员。所以我去了会议，并决定，好吧，我要做一个 hack（黑客作品）。做 hack 的想法是，你应该在参会期间想出 hack 的点子。不要带代码。在参会期间编写代码。Hack 应该具有协作性。虽然不强制。但是，你知道的，召集一群人一起做你的 hack。它可以是任何演示效果很好的东西，对吧？所以我有一个关于在 Mac 上做一个浮动时钟的 hack 的想法。这在 Mac 拥有 Multifinder 之前。所以正如我所说，Mac 一次只能运行一个应用程序，没有线程，
you know, single tasking system. But I just wrote this print spooler, so I knew how to get code to run in the background and draw graphics in the background. What I didn't know how to do was overlay something on the screen, right? We didn't have window compositors or anything like that. The screen was just a big bitmap. And the Mac had a you know windowing system built on something called Quick Draw where you could carve out regions
你知道的，单任务系统。但我刚刚写了这个打印后台处理程序，所以我知道如何让代码在后台运行并在后台绘制图形。我不知道怎么做的是在屏幕上叠加一些东西，对吧？我们当时没有窗口合成器（window compositors）或类似的东西。屏幕只是一大张位图。Mac 有一个内置在称为 Quick Draw 的东西上的窗口系统，你可以通过它划分出区域
right so kind of a window was described by a region which was a compact data structure to represent a bitmap and as a set of inversion points and so I need somebody who knew about regions and there was a guy at the conference whose name I knew, Darren Adler. He had written some articles for a magazine called MacTutor, which later became MacTech. He had written articles about how the window manager regions worked and doing things like how you could draw circular windows. And I thought, OK, he would know how to hack into the window manager so that we could get this clock floating on the screen and so he worked at Apple first day there I approached him at lunch and said you know you don't know me and and I've got this idea for a
对吧，所以某种程度上，窗口是由一个区域（region）描述的，这是一个表示位图的紧凑数据结构，作为一组反转点，所以我需要一个了解区域的人，会议上有一个我认识名字的家伙，达伦·阿德勒（Darren Adler）。他曾为一本名为 MacTutor（后来成为 MacTech）的杂志写过一些文章。他写过关于窗口管理器区域如何运作的文章，以及如何绘制圆形窗口之类的事情。我想，好吧，他会知道如何破解窗口管理器，以便我们能在屏幕上浮动这个时钟，所以他第一天在苹果工作，我在午餐时接近他，并说，你知道的，你不认识我，我有这样一个关于
hack do you want to work on it he said that would be great and so we ended up spending most of the time in I don't even remember if it was his hotel room, but it was one of the Apple people's hotel rooms working on this hack, and he had brought a computer. You didn't have laptops at the time, so I didn't bring a computer. I actually brought a printer, an HP DeskJet,
hack 的点子，你想一起做吗？他说那太好了。所以我们最后把大部分时间都花在——我甚至不记得那是他的酒店房间，还是某个苹果员工的酒店房间里——开发这个 hack，他带了一台电脑。当时还没有笔记本电脑，所以我没有带电脑。我实际上带了一台打印机，一台 HP DeskJet，
to show what you could do with that. We didn't have any copies of inside Mac which were the the Macintosh manuals in paper so to figure out like the OS API calls we were sitting in in what's known as Macsbug which is the Mac is an acronym from Motorola it's not actually Macintosh, but it was a low-level assembly language like GDB or LLDB debugger. So we were figuring out API calls by setting breakpoints on OS functions and watching how the parameters were passed to figure out what the parameters were. And we wrote this system extension that pulled off this floating clock. And it would not only float over windows, it would float over menus,
来展示你可以用它做什么。我们没有任何纸质版的《Inside Mac》（这是 Macintosh 的手册），所以为了弄清楚 OS API 调用，我们坐在被称为 Macsbug 的工具中（Mac 是摩托罗拉的缩写，实际上不是 Macintosh，但它是一个低级汇编语言调试器，就像 GDB 或 LLDB 调试器）。所以我们通过在操作系统函数上设置断点并观察参数是如何传递的来弄清楚 API 调用，从而弄清楚参数是什么。我们编写了这个系统扩展来实现这个浮动时钟。它不仅会浮动在窗口上方，还会浮动在菜单上方，
which at the time the menu system went through kind of a completely different mechanism than the windowing system and even over the menu bar. And so it was a pretty impressive hack. And we took third place. And because I had brought a printer and there were no other printers at the conference and we had to do things like print ballots, you know, for the hack contest. You know, I also got an award for the best commercial hack for my work on the grappler. Wait, if that only got third, then what could have possibly gotten second and first? Because that sounded pretty impressive.
当时菜单系统使用了一种与窗口系统完全不同的机制，甚至会浮动在菜单栏上方。所以这是一个相当令人印象深刻的 hack。我们获得了第三名。由于我带了一台打印机，而且会上没有其他打印机，我们不得不做一些事情，比如打印选票（你知道的，用于黑客松比赛）。你知道的，因为我对 grappler 的工作，我还获得了最佳商业 hack 奖。等等，如果那只得了第三名，那什么才能得第二和第一呢？因为听起来相当令人印象深刻。
Yeah, you know, I don't remember what got, you know, first or second was probably something called net train. You know, most of the things, because who got first or second was based off of what showed well and the last night you had uh you know you you you had this everybody would stand up on stage and present their hack and so there was a fair amount of showmanship involved in in into who the winner
是的，你知道的，我不记得什么得了，你知道的，第一或第二可能是一个叫 net train 的东西。你知道，大多数事情，因为谁得第一或第二是基于展示效果好的东西，而在最后一天晚上你有，呃，你知道的，你有这个——每个人都会站在舞台上展示他们的 hack，所以这其中涉及到相当多的表演技巧，决定了谁将成为赢家
was going to be and flash for the hack and you know a floating clock is fairly utilitarian uh i'm fairly notorious for you know i i uh uh never won best hack but i think i was you know in the the top three without winning the best hack more than anybody so so because i always wrote useful things and those just didn't show well. But yeah, one or two was I think something called NetTrain, which was a train, like a literal animation of a train that would go across your menu bar. And it would go from machine to machine on an AppleTalk network. And so it understood, you know, AppleTalk networks were daisy chained. And so it actually understood the topology
以及 hack 的亮点，你知道的，一个浮动时钟相当实用，呃，我相当“臭名昭著”，因为我，我，呃，从未赢得过最佳 hack，但我认为我进入前三却没拿最佳 hack 的次数比任何人都多。所以，因为我总是编写实用的东西，而那些东西展示效果不好。但是，是的，第一名或第二名我记得是一个叫 NetTrain 的东西，它是一列火车，就像一列真正的火车的动画，会在你的菜单栏上穿梭。它会在 AppleTalk 网络上的机器之间穿梭。所以它理解，你知道的，AppleTalk 网络是菊花链（daisy chained）连接的。所以它实际上理解拓扑结构
of the daisy chain. And so would basically go from machine to machine following the cable around the network. So that's pretty cool. Yep. So that was kind of my first experience. And from that, you know, I ended up spending all this time not with Darren, not just with Darren, but with Scott Boyd and Greg Marriott, who were also from Apple. And they were the ones who ran the hack contest.
菊花链的拓扑。因此它基本上会沿着网络上的电缆从一台机器传到另一台机器。所以这很酷。是的。所以那是我的第一次经历。从那以后，你知道的，我最终把所有的时间都花在跟达伦在一起，不仅是跟达伦，还跟斯科特·博伊德（Scott Boyd）和格雷格·马里奥特（Greg Marriott）在一起，他们也是苹果公司的员工。他们就是运营黑客松比赛的人。
And to this day, I consider Scott, you know, one of my, my, you know, closest friends and, and spent all this, this time working on this hack with, with Darren and impressed Darren. And like two weeks later, I got a phone call from Apple and, and cause Darren had passed my name along. And so that turned into me uh getting a job at apple did we did we tell that story last time i don't know if we told that story last time i don't think we covered sean's apple era yet oh man because this i'm not sure if there's more mac hack stories but if if if because this is like one of the best stories is one of my favorite stories is the how you got a job at apple um yeah the interview process um so it's your it's your choice if you if you have more mac hack uh
直到今天，我都认为斯科特是我最亲密的朋友之一，并且把所有这些时间都花在了和达伦一起开发这个 hack 上，给达伦留下了深刻的印象。大约两周后，我接到了苹果公司的电话，因为达伦把我的名字转达上去了。这让我最终在苹果找到了一份工作。我们上次讲过这个故事吗？我不知道我们上次有没有讲过这个故事。我不认为我们之前讨论过肖恩的苹果时代。哦，天哪，因为这个——我不确定是否还有更多的 Mac Hack 故事，但如果——因为这就像是最好的故事之一，我最喜欢的故事之一就是你是如何在苹果找到工作的，嗯，是的，面试过程。所以这是你的选择，如果你有更多 Mac Hack
we can do more mac hack or you can you can uh we can take a tangent to um how to get a job at apple uh and everyone can take notes yeah this is the this is the surefire way to get a job at apple so so uh right so after this first mac hack um a couple weeks later i get a phone call from apple they want to bring me up for interviews and this was for kind of the next generation printing team at apple for a project that eventually became uh quickGX. And so this was the printing side of QuickdrawGX, which was going to be, well, it shipped. It was going to be Apple's new graphic system. And oddly, the code name for QuickdrawGX is Skia,
我们可以讲更多 Mac Hack，或者你可以，我们可以扯到另一个话题，关于如何在苹果找到工作，每个人都可以做笔记。对，这就是在苹果找到工作的必杀技。所以，呃，对，所以在第一次 Mac hack 之后，几个星期后，我接到苹果公司的电话，他们想让我去面试。这是为了苹果公司下一代打印团队的一个项目，最终演变成了 QuickGX。所以这是 QuickdrawGX 的打印部分，它将成为——嗯，它确实发布了——苹果公司的新图形系统。奇怪的是，QuickdrawGX 的代号是 Skia，
which some of your listeners might recognize because that's the graphic system that's in WebKit. And so two of the principals on Quickdraw GX were Mike Reed and Kerry Clark. And after Quickdraw GX was canceled at Apple, Kerry and Mike Reed started their own company doing a 2D graphics system and sold it to Google. And so that's where Skia comes from. And I discovered this history oddly,
你们的一些听众可能会认出这个名字，因为那是 WebKit 中的图形系统。所以 QuickdrawGX 的两个负责人是迈克·里德（Mike Reed）和克里·克拉克（Kerry Clark）。在苹果取消 QuickdrawGX 后，克里和迈克·里德成立了自己的公司，做了一个 2D 图形系统并把它卖给了谷歌。所以这就是 Skia 的来源。我发现这段历史很奇怪，
you know, a decade ago when I worked briefly at Google and was working on Chrome OS and the graphic system was Skia. And I was like, well, Skia, that's an interesting coincidence. And then I opened the header files and I'm like, no, this skia like I worked on this graphic system how bizarre uh so uh yeah so in any case so so I get this phone call to go work on on quicktry gx and they want to interview interview me uh will stein who I think is back at apple still at apple was the the hiring manager. And so I flew up and spoke with some people on the team, and my last interview of the day was with Will. And Will and I sat down, and I told him what I had been doing at Orange Micro as far as kind of, you know, hacking this printing system.
你知道的，十年前，当我短暂地在谷歌工作并从事 Chrome OS 工作时，图形系统就是 Skia。当时我想，嗯，Skia，这是一个有趣的巧合。然后我打开头文件心想，不对，这个 Skia 就像是我参与过的图形系统，这太离奇了！所以，呃，无论如何，我接到这个电话去从事 quicktry gx 的工作，他们想面试我。威尔·斯坦（Will Stein），我想他现在又回到了苹果，仍然在苹果，是招聘经理。所以我飞过去，和团队里的一些人谈了谈，当天的最后一场面试是和威尔。我和威尔坐下来，我告诉他在 Orange Micro 做打印系统时所做的事情。
And one of the tricks that I did was to get this printing system to work. I actually used Apple's printer drivers to do the rendering. I would just lie to the printer driver about the size of the page to get different resolutions for pages and leverage it. But a big problem you had at the time if you were changing scales or resolutions was that fonts were all bitmap fonts at the time and all hand-tuned and that means that fonts didn't scale linearly. So if you if you doubled the point size of your font it didn't take up twice the width. And so that creates this problem called line layout. And so if you think, you know, an application is sending
我使用的技巧之一是为了让这个打印系统工作，我实际上使用苹果的打印机驱动程序来做渲染。我只是对打印机驱动程序撒谎，谎报页面大小，以便为页面获得不同的分辨率并加以利用。但是当时如果你改变缩放比例或分辨率，你会遇到的一个大问题是，字体在当时都是位图字体，而且都是手工微调的，这意味着字体不能线性缩放。因此，如果你把字体的字号加倍，它不会占用两倍的宽度。这就产生了一个叫做行排版（line layout）的问题。所以如果你认为，你知道的，一个应用程序正在发送
information to the printer by making a whole bunch of graphics calls to draw runs of text or to draw characters, but the printer driver would have to make that look correct as it scaled it up. And so to do that, it would have to make that look correct as it scaled it up. And so to do that, it would have to figure out what was a line of text and then basically re-justify that line of text so that the endpoints hit at the same spot. And so line layout was a fairly complicated algorithm. And so Will asked me in the interview to describe how line layout worked. And so I said, well, you know, the image
通过进行大量图形调用来向打印机发送信息，以绘制文本行或绘制字符，但打印机驱动程序在放大时必须使其看起来正确。为了做到这一点，它必须在放大时使其看起来正确。为此，它必须弄清楚什么是文本行，然后基本上重新调整该行文本的对齐方式（re-justify），使端点落在同一个点上。所以行排版是一个相当复杂的算法。因此威尔在面试中问我行排版是如何工作的。我说，嗯，你知道的，图像
writer LQ driver, this is how line layout works. And I kind walked walked through the algorithm a step at a time and he said no you're wrong I wrote the driver and that's that's not how it works and he gave a different description and I was like I don't even think that that would work no I've you know I've been in this code I've stepped through this code I've taken it apart, you know, at the assembly language level. You know, I know exactly how this algorithm works and you're mistaken. And we got into a very heated argument about the details of this. And so much so that, you know, we weren't paying attention to the time, and I missed my flight back down to Southern California. And so after we kind of wrapped it up, it's like, fine, we agree to disagree.
写入器 LQ 驱动程序，行排版是这样工作的。我一步一步地过了一遍算法，他说不，你错了，那个驱动程序是我写的，根本不是那样工作的。然后他给出了不同的描述。我想，我甚至不觉得那样行得通，不，我一直在研究这段代码，我一步步调试过这段代码，我在汇编语言层面上把它拆解过。我知道这个算法到底是怎么工作的，是你弄错了。我们为了这个细节展开了非常激烈的争论。
We just had this big argument. I'm actually still angry about the whole thing. I go to the airport, and now I have to arrange another plane and sit at the airport and, you know, wait for another flight. And so, you know, now I'm sitting at the airport thinking, oh, I just completely blew my chance of working at Apple. You know, I just got into this heated argument with my hiring manager about how what he was, you know, that he was wrong about code that he wrote himself. And so, you know, flew back down to Southern California and went into work the next day.
以至于，你知道的，我们没有注意时间，我错过了回南加州的航班。所以当我们差不多结束谈话时，好吧，我们同意保留意见（agree to disagree）。我们刚吵了一架。其实我现在对整件事还在生气。我去了机场，现在我不得不安排另一班飞机，坐在机场里，你知道的，等待另一班航班。所以，你知道的，现在我坐在机场里心想，哦，我彻底毁了在苹果工作的机会。你知道的，我刚刚和我的招聘经理发生了一场激烈的争论，关于他自己写的代码，他竟然搞错了。所以，你知道的，我飞回南加州，第二天去上班。
And bright and early in the morning, my phone rang and it was Will. And he said, oh, he was calling to apologize about the argument, and he went back and looked at the sources after our argument, which I thought was somewhat impressive, because I think it was probably six o'clock in the evening by the time we were done, so he didn't just go home, he actually went back and pulled up sources and read through them. And, and he said that, you know, he told me that that I was right, that it worked the way I had described. And, and I was hired. So if anyone has a better hiring story, reach out to us, we'd like to have you on the podcast. I don't recall if it was a hiring story but I recall there's another Sean story
大清早，我的电话响了，是威尔打来的。他说，哦，他是打电话来为争论道歉的，在我们争论之后，他回去查阅了源代码——我觉得这有点令人印象深刻，因为我们结束时可能已经是晚上六点左右了，所以他不仅回了家，还真的回去调出源代码并通读了一遍。而且，他说，你知道的，他告诉我我是对的，它确实像我描述的那样工作。然后，我被录用了。所以如果任何人有更好的求职故事，请联系我们，我们希望你来参加播客。我不记得这是不是一个求职故事，但我记得还有另一个肖恩的故事
where I recall you say something to somebody along the lines of something like somebody was telling you that something couldn't be done and you were like well hire me and I'll come do it for you
我记得你对某人说过类似这样的话，比如有人告诉你某事是做不到的，而你说，好吧，雇我，我来为你做这件事。
was that this particular one or was this another one? No, that was a, that was a much more political thing that you would have to, you know, fast forward until after I left Apple. So, you know, I left Apple after five years and went to Adobe to work on Photoshop. We'll stop it here. Thanks for listening and be sure to tune in next week for our final part, part three of our conversation with Sean Parent
是这个特定的故事，还是另一个？不，那是一个更加政治化的事情，你得快进到我离开苹果之后。所以，你知道的，我在苹果待了五年后离开，去了 Adobe 从事 Photoshop 工作。我们就在这里停下。感谢收听，请务必锁定收听下周的最后一部分，即我们与肖恩·帕伦特对话的第三部分
where he talks about his history with Steve Jobs. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他在那部分谈到了他与史蒂夫·乔布斯的历史。这一集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。